All my friends that come to stay here will stay at the house as long as we're all together.
They all come and say things happen and stuff but, is there a ghost,...
...yes, I've always known there's been a ghost here.
And I do believe, it's Mrs. Carr.
Mrs. Carr was the wife of the original owner, Charlie Carr...
...and she was the lady that took care of this house and died in the ladies' parlor...
...and was laid to rest there.
I'll stay in the house with other people, but I actually don't wish to stay alone.
With all of the sightings, I think that it's a warm spirit.
There's nothing evil about it.
She, having loved the house so much, is so happy...
...that Tony is restoring this to its former glory.
This house has just got so much feeling to it.
Actually, I think every house speaks and has its own story.
And this one has got a good story and a good ending.